Hi, we're the co-founders of Rubric, which is an applied AI lab.
We see so many interesting LLM-based products getting built every day, but we've noticed
that there's just this fundamental difference between a really good demo, like a really
interesting prototype, and a production-grade system that kind of works in the hands of
real people at scale.
Yeah, this is exactly what we do at Rubric.
We architect, build, deploy AI apps, and we've already done this with everyone from
Series B startups to publicly traded companies.
Our process for building products at Rubric is first gathering as much context as possible
to really understand the problem that we're trying to solve.
Once we have the understanding, we want to build a prototype really, really quickly,
validating the hardest part, and zoom in on the things that really matter so that we have
this rich context to solve the problems at hand.
I see us fundamentally as architects.
I think our core strength at Rubric is the ability to take a complex problem and break
it down into a set of discrete chunks.
And once you can lock off a few of those chunks and figure out how to do them really, really
well, suddenly the problem doesn't seem so complex anymore.
And the hard part is those chunks are often LLM calls, which are fundamentally non-deterministic.
They're mushy.
But we want an app to be reliable.
So how do we do that?
Often the products we end up with will have sort of like a large system that's using like
frontier intelligence, like, you know, maybe reasoning models.
When you go to production, you boil them down, you sort of like tune them, and it turns into
a really performant, fast, cheap thing.
Right.
If I can riff on this, also like this semiconductor was such a breakthrough, but you wouldn't
know it if you only had one.
So if the LLM is a breakthrough of like equal magnitude, then trying to optimize one, it
only gets us so far.
We got expectancy systems of like thousands of these combined.
Part of the thesis of why we started Rubrik was because we kind of wanted to challenge
this assumption that you needed a large team and a lot of infrastructure to build these
systems.
We want to be really intentional about being the team that can fill this moment.
By building a framework that really prioritizes experimentation and ideation, while also having
the persistence to actually build a reliable product is what defines Rubrik.
Okay, that's Rubrik.
Thank you so much for your time and please reach out to us.
We would love to hear what you're trying to build and how we might be able to help.
Thank you.